bueno en esta ocasión tenemos pues bueno
esta carrera de autos que vemos que
todos estos autos están corriendo por
esta pista y bueno más más o menos
teniendo una ruta
más o menos en este sentido mi pregunta
para usted es si suponemos que estos
todos estos autos van o tienen una
rapidez
constante
de unos digamos que 100 kilómetros por
hora me interesante preguntar si ustedes
es existe aceleración
bueno ustedes podrían decirme bueno
tenemos una rapidez constante si vemos
el odómetro de estos autos pues no se va
a mover de 100 kilómetros por hora en
todo este tiempo entonces pues si
tenemos esto constante pues uno podría
pensar que no existe aceleración pero es
en este tipo de cosas cuando la
diferencia entre vector y escalar entra
o se nota la importancia tenemos estamos
hablando aquí de la rapidez la rapidez
es una escalar si nosotros estuviéramos
hablando de la velocidad
de la velocidad hasta aparecer pero no
se resuma v velocidad
recuerden que la velocidad tiene
magnitud y tiene dirección entonces si
estamos viendo la velocidad de estos
autos y bueno por lo que yo les estoy
indicando pues fíjense que realmente si
hay una aceleración aunque la rapidez se
mantenga constante
si nosotros viéramos la pista desde
arriba más o menos voy a dibujarla o
tratar de dibujarla supongamos que esta
es una vista de pájaro' de esta pista
estas son las líneas rojas de este lado
más o menos para que ustedes se den una
idea de qué es lo que estamos dibujando
por lo que estamos observando aquí
tenemos nuestras líneas blancas
rápidamente
una idea aunque bueno no estaba
exactamente la escala tenemos aquí esta
parte de pasto verde citó
tenemos aquí un poco de pasto también de
este lado y bueno vamos a enfocarnos en
este auto naranja que está aquí entonces
vamos vamos a dibujarlo acá esto es como
les digo nuestra vista de paja y aquí la
ruta que va a seguir este auto pues va a
ser más o menos está entonces la
velocidad que damos que es una magnitud
pero lo que es un vector entonces este
auto pues bueno va a estar teniendo esta
dirección en este momento pero esta
dirección va a estar cambiando conforme
vaya avanzando para seguir esa curva y
para mantener o para hacer lograr este
cambio de dirección necesita acelerar
para mantener su velocidad llega a esta
parte digamos que va ahora recorriendo
así
y después
llega a esta parte y va girando así
entonces para hacer este cambio de
dirección implica que así vamos a
necesitar una aceleración recordemos que
la aceleración sé que es un vector se
define como el cambio en la velocidad
entre el tiempo o el cambio en el tiempo
entonces la velocidad es un vector vemos
que en este vector que está aquí
pues bueno es un vector que es va a ser
diferente a este vector de aquí igual
habladas para anotar para que lo noten
la longitud de la flecha va a ser la
magnitud del vector entonces estas
flechitas son iguales en su longitud
representando que bueno son tienen la
misma magnitud pero la dirección en la
que están señalando es diferente por eso
es que está cambiando la velocidad estás
este vector es diferente de este vector
y es diferente de este vector
todos estos están cambiando de una
dirección a digamos que hacia dentro de
esta parte de la pista están cambiando
aquí por eso es que hay una aceleración
hay un cambio en el vector durante un
rango de tiempo entonces pues de eso se
trata este vídeo esta pregunta un poco
capciosa pero es para que mediten en
ello y puedan comprender la diferencia
si este vector se mantuviera constante
pues no cambiaré de dirección y este
coche que se seguiría hacia acá en
cambio bueno pues están dirigiéndose
hacia adentro y si me digo hacia adentro
me refiero que está bueno la velocidad y
la dirección de estos autos
está girando hacia el centro de esta
curva vamos a discutir más adelante con
detalle estos trabajos con los vectores
en curvas y por qué es que si se está
haciendo una aceleración cuando estamos
en una curva aunque la magnitud de la
velocidad se mantiene constante pero eso
lo veremos con más detalle mientras
bueno les dejo para que piensen y
reflexionen en esto